[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEN HAMNER: Good
afternoon, everyone.
My name's Ben, and
I am Kaggle's CTO.
Kaggle's building
a platform for you
to do all your data science,
analytics, and machine learning
projects.
So you can both collaborate
on those amongst yourselves,
amongst small teams, as
well as share those publicly
with the world.
But before I get started,
and talking about and demoing
in Kaggle, I want to
get a bit of a better
understanding of who you
are and how familiar you
are with Kaggle.
So let's have a
quick show of hands
for a couple of questions.
First, raise your hands if
you've heard of Kaggle before.
Awesome.
This will make this easy.
Almost everyone has.
Keep your hands up if you
have a Kaggle account.
Looks like about half the room.
Keep your hands up if you've
used a Kaggle data set before,
used data from Kaggle.
Looks like we're dropping
some hands-- maybe 10% of you.
Hopefully in the next
week that will be 100%.
Then keep your hands up if
you've made a submission
to a Kaggle competition.
Almost no one.
One person.
Two people.
Then finally, keep
your hands up if you've
used Kaggle Kernels, or
host a notebook product.
I think two or three people.
Cool.
So let's go ahead and get
started, and swap to my screen.
This session's going to
be entirely demo based.
I figure you're
going to be seeing
a lot of slideshows
and presentations
over the next couple of days.
And I might be biased, but
I love using our products.
So I thought I'd give this
session entirely as a demo,
and walk you through the
different parts of Kaggle.
I'd also love this session
to be a bit more interactive.
So if at any point in
time you have a question,
or you want me to talk
about something else,
there looks like two microphones
on either side of the room.
You can walk over
to one of those
and ask, or just raise your
hand, get my attention,
and shout it down to me, and
I'll repeat your question
so everyone can hear.
When you log into Kaggle, kind
of the first thing that you see
is a news feed of all
the public activity
that's going on in Kaggle.
And you'll see that
there's a really
kind of rich array
of comments about
and code being shared on
data, analytics, and machine
learning.
And this is because we have
a community of nearly two
million users, all
of whom are people
who want to learn
more about data,
and who love using
data in some capacity.
And there's four core
parts of our platform.
There's competitions.
We see these in the header.
Competitions, which is
where we got started.
It's a place for organizations
ranging from commercial users,
to nonprofits, to
research groups,
to publish supervised
machine learning problems
through Kaggle in a way
that our community competes
to develop the best
solution on those problems.
That's where we got
started about a decade ago.
And it's our oldest product.
We also have Kaggle Datasets,
our public data platform,
which has about 8,000
data sets that have been
shared with the world on that.
They can go and consume.
And they're used to cover a
huge range of different topics,
from cryptocurrencies
and financial assets
to tweets of different people to
a bunch of computer vision data
sets.
The third core part of our
platform's Kaggle Kernels,
which is hosted
Jupyter Notebooks.
And we'll dive into that
into much more detail
in a little bit.
And then finally, since
many of our new users
come to us to learn to improve
their skills with analytics
and machine learning,
we really recently
launched a new section
of Kaggle called
Learn, which is a set of short,
bite-size tutorials, that
make it really fast and easy
to get started with analytics
and machine learning, and teach
you just enough to get you
off the ground,
and let you start
working on your own projects.
And diving into
your own projects
is really the fastest
and most effective
ways to learn how to
apply machine learning
and improve your skills there.
So to kick off, we'll
dive into competitions.
When you click into
the competitions,
I see all the
active competitions
that we have on the site right
now that have large prize
monies sponsoring them.
And just to give you
a sense of the array
of different competitions,
the first one I see here
is on identifying salt deposits
between the Earth's surface.
This is a really
important problem
for the energy industry
in oil and gas exploration
and drilling, in that seismic
assets are both very large
and are very challenging
to try to identify what's
the salt deposits in those, as
well as more of the underlying
geological structures.
The next two here are both
with the financial services
industry.
The first is focused on
home credit default risks.
So can you predict the
likelihood of [INAUDIBLE]
paying their home loan.
Then the second is
with Santander Bank
on predicting the
value that transactions
of potential customers
will bring for them.
The fourth competition's
actually with Google AI.
And it's a complex
object detection problem.
So focusing on identifying
dozens of different objects
in an image, and identifying
what the objects are,
as well as where they
are in the image.
And then finally, on
the research side,
the fifth one that we
have shown is with CERN.
And it's on applying
machine learning
to improve our ability
to attract particles
in the Large Hadron Collider.
So you really see from
this kind of the range
of different applications
that we currently are
applying machine learning to.
And we're exposing these
problems to the world.
I'll click into one of these
to go into a bit more detail.
So this is the Home Credit
Default Risk competition,
which is a $70,000
competition where
we've released an
anonymized data set here
of a lot of information
on loan applicants.
And as you look through
this, every machine
learning problem starts with
rich and hopefully high quality
data set.
You'll see many of the
things that you would expect.
I can click through here, and
see that we've split it off
into a train set that you can
use to train a machine learning
model on for different
applications,
and then a test set
that we use to evaluate,
then score how the machine
learning model is doing.
If I scroll down
a bit farther, I
can see a rich data
visualization here.
That's a nice preview of
what's in this data set.
You'll see some of
the usual suspects,
like income, what type of
learner they're looking for,
and things like that,
as well as you'll
see the beloved data that
can be helpful for predicting
the likelihood that
they'll repay their loan.
For example, what is
the credit card balance,
and what other loans
do they have out,
and things along those lines.
Then you see here that 5,000
people have participated
in this competition so far.
That is one of the
really unique things
about being able to pose
a machine learning problem
publicly.
It's the difference
between having
one group of people, or
a small couple of teams
collaborating on the
problem, and having
5,000 people from
all around the world
being able to focus
on the same problem,
and to both collaborate
and compete to get the best
possible result on that.
And this 5,000 teams
isn't just from the US.
They're not just people who
have machine learning PhDs
from Stanford.
Instead, they'll include
things like a English major
from a school in Germany,
or a retired physicist who
wants something that's
more entertaining to do
with his free time from Sudoku.
So it's a really diverse
and international set
of participants that really
helps to democratize both
the raw data machine
learning problems,
as well as the ability to apply
this technology to everyone
around the globe.
If I click through to
our discussion forums,
I'll see that there's a really
rich array of discussion
on this problem that's
really in-depth, looks
at specific considerations and
structuring this as a machine
learning problem, and
cleaning the data,
and what methods tend to
work well on this problem,
and things like that,
where the community is
helping each other out.
Then I can also see how
everyone is currently
doing in this problem
by clicking through
to a leaderboard.
And I'll see here the
score of how people
are doing on this problem.
In this case, users are
predicting the likelihood
of a person paying back a loan.
And this is scored
using a machine learning
metric [INAUDIBLE] the area
under the receiver [? rater ?]
[INAUDIBLE] where 0.5's
random and 1.0 is perfect.
And then you see here
that the top teams are all
clustered very close together.
We have to look
in the third digit
to see a difference between
many of the different top teams.
And this is one of
the things that we
see from having many different
groups around the world
independently working
on the same problem.
They really find all the signal
that's present in the problem.
And the rest tends to
be noise that's either
inherent to the data set itself,
or beyond the current state
of the [INAUDIBLE] machine
learning to handle.
So let's say I wanted to get
started on this problem myself.
How would I go about that?
The first thing I need to do
is get access to the data.
And there's a couple of
different ways I could do that.
I could quick download
and download the data
and start working locally.
We have an API as well.
I could run a command line
command to pull the data down.
I could also use a new
tool that we developed
called Kaggle Kernels.
I can drop in, click
New Kernel here.
And what's going on behind
the scenes right now
is in a Google Cloud VM
and in a Docker container
within that VM, a new
Jupyter Notebook instance
is being created for me.
And then this instance isn't
just a vanilla Python instance.
Instead it has both the
data preloaded into it,
as well as all the libraries
that I may want to use.
And as a quick example of that--
I'll go ahead and
give this a title.
Again, import pandas, which
is a really nice library
for reading in and working,
manipulating tabular data.
We have things like
TensorFlow pre-installed.
And I have Keras in there.
I can pull in my
favorite [INAUDIBLE]
boosting library XGBoost.
I can pull in a
plotting library.
Now who here has had trouble
getting the right Python
libraries installed before, and
gone through a lot of headaches
around that?
OK.
Probably about a third of the
audience, which is probably
the third that's seriously
worked with Python
in any capacity before.
So notice how by
having this in Docker,
and having this
running on a Cloud VM,
I remove the installation
pane from my work.
Out of curiosity,
how many of you
have seen or worked with Jupyter
Notebooks before as well?
Quick show of hands.
Great.
It looks like about
3/4 of you have.
For the quarter that
haven't, Jupyter Notebooks
are a really nice tool that
have kind of become the default
IDE that analysts and machine
learning engineers and data
scientists and that type use for
interactive data exploration.
They're nice because they let
you interleave code, mark down,
and have graphic results
and visualization output
side-by-side in a seamless way.
But one of the things that's
tough with them by default
is versioning.
And one of the things
that we've added to this
is the ability to
hit a button, then
have a clean end-to-end
version run created.
They can then take that, and
share it with my teammates.
They can fork it and
reproduce it very easily.
Or I can click
Publish, and share
that with the broader world.
Another extension
that we've added on,
you'll see if I type something
like A equals hello Next,
I am surfacing my
interactive variables here,
so I know what I've
loaded into RAM,
and what I currently have
available to work with.
Finally, you will see
that I will have access
to the same set of data
previews from the data set
that I've loaded into this.
And if I wanted to
do something like see
what's my training data, or load
that in, then I can copy that.
I can see the histograms
for what's in it,
as well as a quick
preview of the data
while I'm working
with it, then pull
that, then use pandas to
load it into memory here.
Now you see that I have
that pulled into memory now.
So I can continue to work
with that programmatically.
If I wanted to, I can drop in.
I can share this kernel
with my teammates,
who could start working on it.
I could also add a GPU to
accelerate my analysis.
I could add additional
data sources
if I wanted to join to other
data that might help me
with this problem.
I could reference
both public data
that we have, other
competitions' data sets,
as well as the output of any
kernel that's been published
on Kaggle so far.
And then finally,
if I have a use
for having an
internet connection,
we'd block internet by
default to encourage
reproducibility and reproducible
analytics workflows.
But I can easily
click another button,
and have internet
enabled on this instance.
I want to step out of the
interactive environment
now, and drop back into
the benefits of having
an environment like this that's
available for our community.
Now that I click through
here for this competition,
I can see hundreds and
hundreds of code examples
that other users have created
and published on this data set.
For example, this user here made
a really helpful introduction
to new users to
this problem for--
here's the data.
Here's a nice diagram
and some details
for how the data is structured.
Here is the evaluation metric
for my machine learning model,
the [INAUDIBLE] do
the [? RC ?] curve,
as well as how that works.
Here's how I read into that,
the data, into my notebook.
Here are some
exploratory data analysis
consisting of things like
how to do one [INAUDIBLE]
encoding to encode the
feature vectors that I can use
as an input to my
machine learning model,
as well as here are some
univariate relations.
For example, here's
a distribution
of how likely people are
to repay their loans based
on how old they are.
Probably it's not going
to surprise anyone
that younger people are
slightly less likely to repay
their loans than older people.
And then if I keep
scrolling down,
I continue to see
that this user's done
a very rich both
exploratory data analysis,
as well as has
showed how to train
a number of different machine
learning models on this data
set.
So when I start working
with this problem,
it's not like I'm starting
with just the raw data,
or an empty cursor.
I have the benefits of all
the work that other users have
created on the same
problem, that I
can read those and leverage
those as a starting point.
I see here that this
kernel's been very popular.
Over 200 people have
left comments on it.
This user's ran 15
different versions of it,
which I can click
through and see
if I want to understand how
he's developed this over time
how the different
versions have progressed.
As well as over 2,000 people
have forked it, and then
taken this and built
on this, and use it
as their own starting point.
And when I press
Fork, what's happening
is I'm spinning up
the same environment
that this user is using
when he created the kernel.
And then that makes
it really easy
for me to reproduce his code.
So I can go through here.
Then I see not all of my
cells have run so far.
But if I hit Run All, it's
going to run this notebook
top to bottom.
It's going to start
loading in the data.
And then I get the
same set of information
that this user who created
it available and reproducible
with a click of a button.
Out of curiosity,
how many of you
have had trouble
reproducing work that you
found before, either
online, or in literature,
or some random code example that
was shared as a GitHub, or et
cetera?
Yeah, it looks like
most of you have.
So one of my goals over
the next five years
is to make zero people
raise their hands when
I ask that question again.
And you see here, this is
going to tend to run through.
But this end-to-end reproduction
should work seamlessly,
thanks to underlying
technologies
like data versioning,
code versioning,
and versioning the computational
environment through Docker
containers.
I'm going to click out of this.
And that's a segue into the next
part of Kaggle, our open data
platform.
So this part is a
part of Kaggle that we
launched about two years ago.
And in the past
two years our users
have published nearly
10,000 data sets
on Kaggle, many of which are
really high quality and well
curated data sets that
they've shared with the world.
If you wanted to work with
your own data on Kaggle,
it's really easy.
You click new data set.
And then you can either drag
and drop files to upload them.
You can use our API to
polish them directly
from the command line.
And you'll have a couple
of options, as well.
You'll put a title in.
You can choose whether
it's private or public.
Many users start off
with private data,
then keep it private as they're
working on their own side
projects and hobbyist
projects for their own work.
Many others start
private initially
to upload it, work on it a
little bit to clean it up,
and then ultimately make
it public to the world.
And then just to give
a couple examples
of some of the different
types of data here,
you see that ranges from
New York City public data
to things like sports
results to this
is a good computer
vision data set
for different species of
monkeys here, and being
able to go through and
identify the different species
of monkeys, like this one.
And then if I want to
pick different topics
and find data appropriate
for my problem,
let's say I'm working
in a financial problem.
I might be interested
in stock data.
I can do a quick search and
see that there's over 100 data
sets that have different
variations of both US
and international stock data.
Another area that's been
popular recently is bitcoins.
So I can see that we have a
number of cryptocurrency data
sets available as well across
several different currencies.
If I'm trying to train
a computer vision model,
I might be looking
for image data.
So I'll search for
images, and see
what I have available as
a starting point there.
I could also be, say,
trying to train a sentiment
classifier on an NLP problem.
Then I can see that
there's hundreds
of starting points for
sentiment analysis and text
classification that I
can take and leverage.
I'll pull a couple of these
up in a bit more depth.
The first will be
a movie data set.
And then, when I click
in this data set,
first I can see very quickly
what's in the data itself.
In this case, this
one's metadata
on almost 50,000 movies,
with 26 million ratings
from over 270,000 users.
A click can go in
a bit more depth,
and see that it includes
the things I'd expect,
like who's in the movie--
what's the cast and the crew.
A lot of metadata with a movie--
for example, what's its budget?
How much money did it make?
What language is it in?
Here's a quick
summary of the movie,
how popular it was, a lot
of things along those lines.
And then as well
as a ratings data
set, where the hundreds
of thousands of users
rated these movies on
a scale of one to five.
Then the other unique thing
about publishing data--
kind of two other
unique things--
is first we version
everything by default.
So you don't have to worry
about versioning, or if someone,
you do an update
to the data set,
then it's really easy to
see that you did the update
and then to understand
what happened.
One of the really common
pain points that we've seen
is different users
or different teams
are working on different
versions of the same data set,
and aren't aware that they're
working on different versions
of the same data set.
So one will change
it in one place,
but not change it in the other.
Or they'll update the data
set, but not the description,
and things like that.
So one of our goals is
to make it really easy
to see when the data
changed, as well
as what changed with the data.
The second thing is we have
kernels available on data
sets as well.
And we have a way to go
through, and for any data set
see all the code that's been
written and shared publicly
on that data set.
So again, for any
data that you publish,
you don't just get the
advantage of here's
a quick way to publish
and share data online.
We actually see the
results that users
create on that, and the
analyses that they create.
One user pair trained a nice
set of recommendation engines,
and gave examples of how to do
both popularity based, content
based, and collaborative
filtering approaches to movie
recommendations in here.
And if I wanted to take that,
and reproduce it and extend it,
again I could click Fork
and run with it just right
from my browser there.
Whoops.
Opened that twice.
Another user here was interested
in some of the history of film,
and looked back and at
things such as where
did the movies
originate from, and what
are some of the most popular
and highest-grossing movie
franchises of all times.
So for answering
questions like this,
if I'm coming at this
from another angle,
I'd just be working
with this data set,
a random CSV file I
downloaded off the internet,
pulling it up locally, then
doing all this analysis myself.
Instead, I have the benefit
of going through and being
able to see all the analyses
that other people have created
on this.
So I can both use this as
inspiration for my own work,
and don't need to repeat work
that others have already done.
Another of my favorite
public data sets
is one that we
released ourselves.
So we make most of the data that
we can make available publicly
on Kaggle.
So things that show up on the
data sets and competitions,
or the public versions
of each of those,
they're available to
our users for analytics.
So I can see things
like here's the CSV
file of all the public
competitions that we've hosted.
Or to get a bit
meta, can go in here
and see here's the different
public data sets that we have.
And I can actually find
this data set here,
where I see this
little row represents
the data set that I'm
currently seeing on this page.
And we've really been blown
away by how all of our users
have used this.
Whoops.
Looks like this is down.
But this is our really
actively used data set.
We see dozens and dozens
of discussion and analytics
created on it each day.
Two examples of
those are one user
wrote an automated
kernel to pull out
where are all the winning
solutions of Kaggle
competitions.
Many users will publish
their winning solution
in a forum post with
a link to the code
that they used to create it.
So this user went
through and searched,
pulled out for all of
our popular competitions
here's the things
that say "solution"
in the title ordered
by number of up-votes,
and kind of the activity on
it as a quick way to identify
here's a list of hundreds and
hundreds of highly competitive,
state-of-the-art machine
learning solutions that have
been created and
shared on Kaggle.
So if I want to work on
something like iceberg
classification for
satellite images,
I can come to this kernel.
I can click on the
winning solution for that.
And then I can quickly
understand what is
the state-of-the-art
on this problem,
as well as how did this
team approach this,
not just in theory,
but in practice--
how did they segment
the data and analyze it,
and what did they
do that worked?
In a similar vein,
another user realized
that we have a lot
of people sharing
really helpful
tutorials for how to do
various analytics, machine
learning, and AI projects,
and work on Kaggle, and
created a set of topics,
and then pulled out here's the
best kernels on Kaggle for each
of these topics, ranging
from linear regression,
logistic regression, to
XGBoost, to deep learning,
and convolutional
neural networks,
to clustering algorithms,
through to a lot
of other things that
don't get a lot of buzz,
but are really important for
anyone applying analytics
and machine learning
in practice,
like doing high-quality
exploratory data analyses
so you understand what's
actually in the data set
that you're working with,
and how to do feature
engineering, and components
along those lines.
And again, one of the
cool things about this
is that this isn't
something that they
had to go through and
manually pull together.
Instead, they were able
to create this analysis
in our public data set
in a way that's actually
produced and updated over time.
I'm going to go ahead and go
into the last bit of Kaggle
for a little bit, then open back
up for questions at the end.
We heard from many
of our newer users
that they really
wanted more material
to get started in data
science and machine learning.
So about six months
ago, we launched
a new section of Kaggle
called Kaggle Learn that's
run through kernels.
And then this is a set of
about 10 different courses,
each of which consist of around
five to 10 different tutorials
and exercises that take
a week to go through,
covering areas like Python
for our analytics and machine
learning, or using SQL
as a data scientist,
or here's how to get started
with your first machine
learning models.
And our goal for
these is to teach you
just enough that you
can use to get started
with your own machine
learning work,
and then to get you
onto your own projects
as quickly as possible.
Because we believe
that you learn the most
from starting to work, and
figuring out what works
and what doesn't on
your own projects,
versus spending a lot of time
following a very structured
course and curriculum.
So just as one example of
[INAUDIBLE] first starting
the first machine
learning project.
We used a house
price prediction data
set for this, where
based on things
like how many square
feet is in your house,
and components like that, how
many bedrooms do you have,
predict the sales
price of the home.
And this is also something
we're considering
how to take community
contributions from as well.
So if you're inspired to use
Kaggle as a teaching platform,
then I'd love to speak
to you afterwards.
I'd encourage you, if there's
an area of analytics, or data
science, or machine
learning that you
want to explore more of,
to check out Kaggle Learn,
and to get started
there to start
applying it to your own work.
[MUSIC PLAYING]